c'est parti début à paris du chantier de
la tour triangle ou plutôt de la tour de
la discorde il dira mais de pharaon
qu'est-ce que vous pouvez demander à
monsieur delanoë s'est finalement il
veut pas s'immortaliser dans la pierre
septembre 2008 début du projet bertrand
delanoë alors maire de paris veut
construire une nouvelle tour de 180
mètres de haut en plein coeur du 15e
arrondissement le but redynamiser le
quartier du parc des expositions nous
devons absolument au niveau du parc des
expositions donner à ce parc les moyens
nécessaires pour qu'il soit compétitif
et que paris reste compétitif dès le
début le projet est critiqué pollution
visuelle problèmes de circulation pas
écologique pour l'opposition politique
et certains riverains c'est clair la
tour triangle ne doit pas sortir de
terre détruits l'harmonie du quartier
c'est absolument indispensable de
supprimer ce projet face à cette grogne
l'avenir de l'atome reste en suspens
trois ans plus tard en 2011 elle est
toujours prévu mais aucune trace du
chantier à l'horizon et les opposants au
projet continuent leur combat le volant
est nombreux et nous voulons pouvoir
faire
100 200 300 procès à qui il faudra
arrêter cette heure 2014 anne hidalgo
devient maire de paris et la tour
triangle de s'éloigne un peu plus le
projet doit d'abord être validée par un
vote au conseil de paris le 17 novembre
après un débat houleux les élus donnent
leur dernier
pour 78 contre 83 il ya
c'est non le conseil de paris rejette le
projet des architectes jacques herzog et
pierre de meuron les priorité c'est
d'investir pour le logement c'est
d'investir pour les transports publics
c'est d'investir pour les équipements
publics ce projet de tour triangle
c'était un projet de tour de bureaux je
dirais presque ordinaire et banale la
tour triangle définitivement abandonné
eh bien non un an plus tard en 2015
nouveau vote au conseil de paris cette
fois les élus votent pour mais malgré
cette validation certains riverains
continuent de s'y opposer en 2018 trois
associations portent plainte contre la
ville de paris pour délit de favoritisme
c'est quand même scandaleux
la ville de paris fait construire par le
promoteur privé un immeuble qui va lui
revenir dans 81 ans et dont elle sera
propriétaire ces plaintes n'irons pas
plus loin en 2019 la justice les rejeter
valide définitivement le projet la fin
des travaux est prévue pour 2026 la tour
triangle deviendra le troisième plus
haut édifice de paris derrière la tour
montparnasse et la tour eiffel
[Musique]